We learned several videos ago
that if I had an infinite
uniformly charged plane-- let me
draw one right here, and I
won't draw it infinite and
I'll tell you why in a
second-- that if we had an
infinite uniformly charged
plane, and let's say this
one's positive, that the
electric field generated
by it is constant.
Those are the field lines.
They should all be
the same size.
And the strength of the field,
or the magnitude of the field,
is equal to 2 times Coulomb's
constant times pi times the
charge density of the plate.
So if this is infinite-- so
what was charge density?
We defined it when we proved
that this truly is a uniform
electric field, but what
is charge density?
Charge density is just the total
amount of charge divided
by the area, or charge
per area.
Well, if we have an infinite
plane, the area's going to be
infinite, and so if this is a
constant number, this is also
going to be infinite, so it's
kind of hard to work with.
But what we also know is that
when we have a non-infinite
plane that has some finite area,
that near the center of
it and fairly close to it, it
approximates an infinite
uniformly charged plane.
So with that said, let's see if
we can figure out some of
the properties of the voltage
and how the voltage relates to
the charge.
If we were to have two
parallel-- let me draw it
before I say it, because I
think saying it'll just
confuse it.
So let's say I have two plates,
that plate-- and then
I'll do this one in a different
color-- and I have
that plate, and let's say
they're the same size and they
both have area A.
Let's say that I place plus
Q worth of charges here.
So this is plus Q so this is
positively charged, right?
I could draw a bunch
of charges here.
Let's say this is minus Q, so
this is negatively charged.
So what's the electric field
going to look like
between these two?
Well, it's essentially going to
be the combination of the
electric field generated by
this plate on top of the
electric field generated
by this plate.
And they're both going to be
constant close to the center,
assuming that they're
reasonably-- and let's say
that they're d apart.
Assuming that d isn't too big,
near the center we're going to
have a constant electric
field.
For example, this green one is
going to be generating-- its
field lines are going to look
something like this.
Near the center,
it's constant.
These are meant to
look constant.
Near the center, it'll look like
that, and it'll start to
bulge out when you
get to the edges.
Once again, near the center,
it's constant.
That one should've
been at an angle.
They start to bulge out,
and it'll look
something like that.
And similarly, this purple plate
will generate a constant
electric field, and since it's
negatively charged, the field
lines will be going towards it,
not away from it, so its
field lines are going to look
something like this.
Near the center, they'll be
constant, and its field lines
are going to look something
like that.
As you can see, they're going
to be of the same magnitude
and in the same direction,
and they also
will bulge out there.
So the big picture is that you
just kind of have twice the
electric field as you would have
if you just had one of
these plates.
So let's say we're operating
near the center of these,
where we have roughly a constant
electric field and
see if we can figure out the
relationship between the
voltage across these two plates
and the area, and maybe
the distance between
the two plates.
So we know that the electric
field generated by any one of
these charge plates-- I'll do it
in the blue of this color.
So for the bottom plate right
here, what is the electric
field generated?
It's 2K pi times sigma.
Sigma is just the total charge
divided by the area.
So Q/A, right?
And we know that the total
electric field generated by
this one is going to be
essentially the same thing.
I mean, we could say it's a
minus, a negative, because
it's going towards it, but it's
essentially the same thing.
Because we see that they overlap
just drawing the field
line, so the electric field
from that one, and we know
that they go in the
same direction.
If this was somehow-- well, this
is negative, so the field
lines go towards it.
So plus 2K pi and this is Q/A.
We could have said minus and
then had a minus Q/A, but we
know that they go into same
direction, so we know that
they're going to be additive.
And so we know that the total
electric field is
going to be 4K pi Q/A.
So now we know the
exact strength of
the electric field.
Let's see if we can figure out
the voltage difference between
this point and this point.
What was voltage difference,
just as a review?
Well, voltage difference is
the electrical potential
energy per charge if the charge
was here versus here.
So how much more potential
energy per coulomb is there
for a charge to be here
relative to here?
So another way to view it is a
charge here, a positive charge
here, because by default we're
always assuming a positive
charge when we talk about
positive numbers and the
direction of the field lines
or what the positive
charge would do.
So by default, a positive charge
here really wants to go
up to this negative plate,
although we later learned that
most of the movement in
electronics and electricity,
it's actually the negative
charge that's moving.
It's the electrons moving.
But let's say we did
have a positive ion
or a positive charge.
The voltage is a measure of if
any charge is here, how badly
does it want to move to this
point if it has a way to move?
If we have air here or if we
have a vacuum here, it might
be difficult or impossible
for it to move up here.
But maybe if we were to connect
a wire where the
charges could freely conduct,
then it will move.
And the voltage is just
kind of how badly
does it want to move?
You could almost view it
as electrical pressure.
And maybe I'll do a whole video
on trying to get an
intuitive understanding of
voltage, because that really
is probably the most important
thing to get an intuitive
understanding of, if you ever
want to study electrical
engineering or whatever.
But anyway, back
to the problem.
We know that the combined
electric field is this, right?
It goes upwards in
that direction.
So what is the electric
potential at this point
relative to this point or
the potential difference
from here to here?
Well, that's the amount of
energy per charge it would
take to move a positive charge
from here to there, right?
Remember, electric potential
energy is the amount of work
necessary to move a charge from
there to there, and then
the voltage is how much
to do it per charge.
Let me write that down.
So the work necessary to move a
charge from there to there--
let's say a 1-coulomb charge, it
will be 1 coulomb times the
electric field, because we're
always going to have to be
going against the
electric field.
So we have to apply an equal
and opposite force.
So the force that is going to
be the electric field-- so
far, this just generates this
force. coulomb times electric
field, charge times electric
field, tells us the force on
the charge, right?
That's force, and
then we have to
multiply that times distance.
Force times distance.
So we see the work necessary
is going to be the electric
field times d joules-- the J is
joules-- and so what is the
voltage difference or the
electric potential difference
between this point
and this point?
Let's call that point a.
Let's call that point b.
So Va minus Vb, which is the
voltage difference, that's
essentially the electric
potential energy difference
divided by the charge.
Or, per charge.
Well, here, the charge was just
1, so we can just divide
by 1, and we see that it is
equal to the electric field
times the distance.
And the units are going to be
joules because we divided both
sides by charge joules per
coulomb, or volts, right?
That's just the units.
So what does that equal?
So the voltage difference-- so
we can say change in voltage.
The voltage difference is equal
to the electric field,
which we know is constant 4K
pi Q over A times distance.
Or we could rewrite this.
Let's see if we could write
Q as a function of V.
So if we just do a little bit of
algebraic manipulation, we
can get Q is equal to what?
We would essentially divide
both sides by 4 pi Kd and
multiply both sides by
A, so we would get A
over 4K pi d voltage.
And why is this interesting?
Why did I go through all of
this work to get this
relationship?
Well, what it shows you, if you
look at this, if we assume
that the area of the plates
aren't changing-- that's a
constant; this is definitely a
constant-- and if we assume
that the distance between the
plates don't change, what we
see is that there's a
proportional difference
between the voltage and the
amount of the combined charge
in the plates.
And that's interesting because,
before doing this,
maybe voltage is somehow
proportional to the square of
the charges or to the square
root, but now we know that
it's directly proportionally.
And actually, this term right
here has a name, and it is
called capacitance.
And so another way of rewriting
this, if we divide
both sides by voltage, we get
Q/V is equal to 1 over 4K pi
area over distance.
And so what it essentially says
is that the amount of
energy that-- well, actually,
I don't want to
go into that yet.
But for a given configuration,
and the configuration is
defined by the area of the
plates and the distance-- for
a given configuration, if I know
the amount of charge that
I put onto the plates, if I did
a minus Q here and a plus
Q here, I know the voltage
across the
plates or vice versa.
If I know the voltage across
the plates and I know its
configuration, I know how much
charge there is, and this is
called capacitance, and the
unit for capacitance
is called the Farad.
And if you become an electrical
engineer or even
take a couple of electrical
engineering courses, you'll
become very familiar
with this.
And one other thing to point
out; this term right here,
just so you know a little
bit of terminology.
This term right here.
This 1 over 4K pi, this is often
called epsilon nought,
or just epsilon, and that's
called the permittivity of
free space or permittivity
of the vacuum.
And maybe in a future lecture
or a future video, I'll talk
more about why it's
called that.
But anyway, I'm already well
over the time limit.
So I just wanted to give you a
sense of, one, that you can
calculate the voltage across
what we call, in
this case, a capacitor.
It has capacitance.
That voltage, you can
kind of view it as
the electric pressure.
How bad does the charge here
want to move here?
And if you put a wire here,
you'll learn in a second-- not
in a second, in several
videos-- that
that charge will flow.
Or actually the negative charges
will flow this way and
generate current.
And we'll do that when we start
learning a little bit
more about electricity.
For any given configuration,
it has a corresponding
capacitance, and then given
that capacitance, if I put
some amount of charge, I can
figure out the voltage, or if
I know there's some voltage, I
can figure out the charge.
Anyway, I will see you
in the next video.